a multi-million dollar renovation is
underway at the circus circus from the
adventure dome to the pool changes are
coming but property officials say the
essence of the resort will remain
i hope we enjoy it and i think we will
come back here it was four days of fun
for this family from the philippines a
first in las vegas and at circus circus
it was a nice experience they all tell
us it's a pretty old building but i
don't think so it was well maintained it
was well managed it has great
entertainment package the landmark
resort on the las vegas strip is looking
to attract more families as it undergoes
renovations since it was recently
acquired by phil ruffin circus circus is
a very
iconic property we're trying to bring it
back to the glory days of when it was
built in the 1950s over the past couple
years circa circus spent around 30
million dollars on expanding the pool
redesigning the food court and adding
new rides at the adventure dome and it's
definitely kid approved i like to come
back here
and the midway
games is super fun we want the littler
guys we want the ones that are 33 inches
that they can get on rides they can ride
they can have have fun property
officials say the interior renovations
are expected to be completed by next
spring the next phase will include a
hotel upgrade and a fresh look to the
exterior the abot family says it's all a
good look i did enjoyed it and i win
some coins last night on the
chain changer